I'm Alex Villareal with the VOA Special English Economics Report.
They are not even five millimeters long and cannot fly or jump.
Yet bedbugs strike fear in homeowners and business owners.
Missy Henriksen speaks for the National Pest Management Association.
She says they are now seeing bedbugs in unusual places.
Schools and hospitals, stores, and movie theaters.
So, as the numbers have grown,...
...those bedbugs are spreading out and traveling along with people.
Mr. White says bedbugs nearly disappeared from the United States for 50 or 60 years.
Now, researchers are looking for faster, safer ways to control them...
...without the kinds of poisons used in the past.
In September, an industry event called BedBug University's North American Summit 2010...
...took place near Chicago, Illinois.
More than 360 people attended the 2-day meeting.
The industry says bedbugs are the most difficult pest to control.
Treatments can cost from several hundred dollars to thousands of dollars in a hotel or apartment building.
Missy Henriksen says Americans spent almost 260 million dollars on bedbug treatments last year.
That was only 5% of total spending on pest control,...
...but that number does not include other costs.
She says the total economic effect is much greater.
Businesses that have bedbugs often must close to solve the problem.
Bedbugs have not been shown to spread disease.
But they can leave itchy bite marks and cause allergic reactions in some people.